hello I'm Christopher Hine and today
we're going to be talking about the ice
pick grip and what the ice pick grip is
uh I call it a reverse grip usually so
when you have a knife in your hand
either it sticks out the four side the
front side or the back side the reverse
side um so I'm going to talk a little
bit about the knife disarms I use for um
reverse grip which are basically
essentially the same as the other ones
but I'll kind of give you some detail on
them we'll talk a little bit about them
so I'm going to get Josh over here we're
going to go to work Josh
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so let's talk about the
reverse grip so understand reverse grip
and forgrip are roughly the same when it
comes to doing disarms with them uh one
important thing to understand is a
reverse grip seriously limits your
striking range um so if I was here with
Josh and I'm just barely in Striking
range here right so if I moved I'd cut
him now I'm not going to change anything
but the grip okay so I just changed the
grip and now I'm about six inches from
Josh's neck so he is way further away
from me than he was before okay uh
because of the position of the knife
that's it so when maximum distance is
important to me I want to be in a four
grip and not in a reverse grip most aita
schools use the four grip and don't use
the reverse grip probably for this very
reason because making distance is
essentially what we want to do whether
we're offensive or defensive with the
knife um now when I am coming over head
strikes this is much more comfortable
than this so because we have yokan and
Showman's putting it in the reverse grip
is going to make more sense for a lot of
people and especially when you start
moving into free practice you're going
to see this happening a lot although a
lot of people get in this position just
because they think it's cool right it's
a cool position generally it's it's not
great unless you're up close or coming
down directly with these attacks so use
Niko all right so uh as Josh comes down
I'm going to use the same basic thing
before so he used a yokan here's my UD
sanaku there's the knife and I I'm I'm
readily available to to get to it okay
now if I were to drive him down like
this okay as I drive it down we get
kotay here exactly the same as we would
get it in the foregrip right so it's
different in like uh in in his hand like
the way he's holding it but for me it's
exactly the same strip no different
right now I might have to use the flat
of the blade more or use the backside of
the blade more because I don't have a
handle here as nicely to slide up kind
of depends these are short-handled
knives so these are actually pretty
challenging for this but a longer
handled knife it's going to give me a
little more control over that but that's
exactly the same let's say it came gaku
yokuman like this okay Niko is also
right there exactly the same so here it
is Boom there's Niko strips out in my
hand exactly the same so that's really
not any different comes out quickly
there are some other little cool things
so there's some stuff from an Italian
fencing man manual that I stole that I
think's really cool so if Josh comes in
I go like this now if I keep it against
the flat of my forarm I'm going to get a
kot here right so I come over boom and
it pops out kod right into my hand and
then I can use that same attack on him
and then he gets the flat of the blade
boom turns it over and we can do
progressions with this right so like say
he pulls that away so I miss it there
okay I come up here and I get it on this
side and there's our Koda right or if I
do that and he turns his hand the
opposite way right like this then I get
the Niko so the same kinds of drills we
had for the um the for grip we can do in
the reverse grip so uh there's lots of
cool fun stuff the more you work with
the reverse grip the more it will be
comfortable to you but understand that
it it's it's usefulness is kind of
limited although it seems awesome think
about you know you Hammer with a hammer
in the forgrip you don't Hammer with a
hammer in the reverse grip because
you're more powerful and more confident
with it in a forgrip than a reverse grip
so in martial arts people think it's
neat that you know like ninjas hold
things in Reverse grips and they're
really cool and you know you can do this
kind of sneaky thing right so like oh I
have a knife and he would never know and
then oh I do a do a thing you know so it
seems like cool cool sweet martial arts
stuff but it it's not actually all that
amazing one of the other things that you
should understand whenever you're
disarming whether it's in the four grip
or the reverse grip cut okay so so um
one thing to understand when you're
doing this is that uh the knife's going
to come out in the the same way you take
it out right that sounds silly but
meaning if Josh is in a reverse grip
which he is right now and and I take it
out with Sono right now if I come in and
my hand matches Josh's then it will come
out in reverse grip for me right so look
now I have reverse grip for Josh if I do
opposite so this is the same if I do
opposite so now my hand's opposite Josh
when I strip that knife the knife will
come out in the four grip for me right
so however the hands are put if I put my
hand matching his hand it will be in the
same grip for me as it was for him if I
go opposite then it will be opposite
grip than it was for him right which
seems kind of like a no-brainer but it
was a while of doing this before I
realized like oh yeah if I want the
knife in my hand in a foregrip I've got
to do whatever is reciprocal for how
he's doing it so um that's it ice pick
grip or reverse grips not a big
difference um the more you practice it
the more you'll get good at it I'm Chris
fry this Joshua te my salon McDaniel
behind that handheld camera right now so
if it's Mega shaky then it's because
she's handheld and she's practicing her
human tripod Powers but we'll see you
guys in the next video
[Music]